our experts believe and the data shows
that most of the price increases we've
seen
are were expected and and expected to be
temporary
there's nobody suggesting there's
unchecked inflation on the way
no serious economist let's check that no
unchecked inflation claim
now if you have a car it costs you twice
as much to run it as it did last year
fuel prices have doubled your daily
breakfast now comes with an eight
percent price hike
as the cost of milk bacon and fruit have
gone up
on top of that you've got consumer
prices that have hit their highest
amount since
2008. now despite the president's
assurances america's working families
already being hard hit by the pandemic
are starting to feel the pinch the
groceries are definitely up
and also the rents are also going up and
just household items we're making
serious progress to ensure that it works
the way it's supposed to work
for the good of the american people well
construction material is out of this
world
somebody's making some good money and i
think it's because joe biden we could
help
families and small businesses whether
the ups and downs or as the economy
recovers
i don't buy anything honestly what the
government even says nowadays i truly
truly know
look we brought this economy back from
the brink
now biden refuses to hear those voices
perhaps he'll listen to those within his
own party
labor market tightness behavior of
housing markets and asset prices
all rising in a more concerning way than
i worried a few months ago
this raises my degree of concern
overheating scenario
there are huge uncertainties but the
focus of concern now should be on
overheating
and if that's not enough to change the
president's mind on the economy
perhaps this comparison is the wake-up
call he needs
the u.s is in a very bad position from a
long-term point of view
i don't see how these can end well when
we are running now
budget deficits something like 15
percent of gdp
this is beginning to look a little bit
like a latin american country
printing and spending money like there's
no tomorrow has pretty clearly got
people concerned biden
gave the excuse that the spending is
necessary to tamp down inflation which
is ridiculous that is nothing in common
uh the you can't stop the
consequences of monetary printing by uh
doing even more monetary printing which
is what it means to spend this level of
money and the fact
is that uh biden and all of his advisors
and the political party that he
represents
are big spenders and they want to spend
more money they think that the us
government can go into infinite amounts
of debt
there's no limits whatsoever they really
believe this biden assures us the
problems are just
temporary but perhaps it's a bit like
the pandemic and the economic aftermath
it's a bigger problem than was first
thought but it seems to be a problem
that biden's apparently incapable of
recognizing
caleb maupin rt new york
you